منذ اللحظه الاولى كان دخول ايلون ماسك
مقر شركه تويتر مليئا بالمفاجات اذ دخل
باستهزاء حاملا حوض غسيل في اشاره منه الى
التغييرات الجذريه التي سيقوم بها وفور
الاستحواذ على الشركه صرح الى الماسك
حوالي نصف موظف الشركه حول العالم واغلق
مكاتبها مؤقتا في محاوله لخفض التكاليف
وفرد قيم عمل جديده وفق ما يراه مناسبا
وان اتت بنتائج عكسيه
ما كان عليه تويتر لمستخدمي في جميع انحاء
العالم لم يعد موجوده فهي منصه غير مستقره
ولا يمكن التنبؤ بما سيحدث لها حيث نشهد
زياده في اللغه المتطرفه للغايه ومحتوى
يقول ماسك ببساطه انه حريه التعبير وللاسف
تجاوزنا هذه النقطه
لم تتوقف مشاكل تويتر عند تقليص القوه
العامله وللتاخر في دفع مستحقات ايجارات
مكاتبها ومن بينها مكتب لندن هذا بل امتدت
الى الاعطال المتكرره المفاجئه في ست
مناسبات منذ اواخر اكتوبر الماضي حرمت
المستخدمين في جميع انحاء العالم من
التفاعل عبر المنصه او نشر التغريداتهم
الى جانب قرارات تعليق حسابات صحفيين او
اعاده اخرى ابعدت شرائح واسعه من
المستخدمين كما اوقفت كبرى شركات التسويق
اعلاناتها على تويتر ما ادى الى تراجع
ايرادات وارباح الشركه
ابقاء المعلنين على منصه تويتر والحفاظ
على انفاقهم امر بالغ الاهميه والسبب في
تخلي هؤلاء المعلنين عن المنصه هو المحتوى
الصام الذي لا يريدون ان ترتبط اسمائهم به
وهذا يمثل مخاطره اكبر الان للعلامات
التجاريه لان القدره الرقابيه على المحتوى
في تويتر تضاءلت بشكل كبير بسبب تقليص عدد
الموظفين
هذا هو يطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي الى النصر
بتعيين المزيد من الوسطاء ومدقق الحقائق
لمراجعه المشاركات وفق القواعد الاوروبيه
لمراقبه المحتوى عبر الانترنت
مشاكل شركه تويتر منذ تولي ايلون ماسك
زمامها لا تنتهي ما فتح الباب امام علامات
تجاريه منافسه للصعود في سلم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ورغم ذلك خبراء كثر ما
زالوا يعتقدون ان بامكان ماسك اعاده تويتر
الى مكانه عليه اذا ما تعامل مع الشركه
على انها منصه رقميه عالميه وليست مصنع
سيارات
مستفزاروه العربيه لندن